i heard princess diaries three there's
something in the works is this true
i've heard that rumor as well and people
have asked me if i
would be a part of the film and my
answer is i have no idea i i have i have
heard nothing about it other than the
rumors that are out in the zeitgeist i
kind of feel like um
i i my character was sort of you know
the nemesis to anne hathaway's character
in the first film
and she was so mean i feel like
maybe there's no place for her although
the other angle is like redemption
exactly redemptive like she's she's done
a 180 she's turned her life around and
she and mia become really good friends
so
i would be game i mean anne hathaway
julie andrews like that was such a a
pivotal seminal moment in in my life i
feel like i just saw a room of writers
go
like i think that would work i would
love to see you in it okay so you're on
tour
and
will you tell us what happens while
you're on tour
yes so um i put an album out and uh i
haven't been on tour in 15 years i
started off in the music industry
and i thought you know what i worked um
pretty much like most of my pregnancy on
the show last time uh this is my second
baby so i was like i i feel like i can
do it and we got through like the first
half of the tour
only just to realize like i i feel like
i've hit my my limit and i really need
to focus on my health and the health of
the baby and so unfortunately we had to
cancel
the remaining half of the tour which was
devastating and and just so
disappointing i think as a woman like we
really pride ourselves on trying to do
not do it all but do as much as we can
and i was i didn't want to let anybody
else down i didn't want to let myself
down so it was
it was a difficult decision to come to
but i i love it and i can't wait to do
it again but definitely not
six and a half months pregnant that was
that was a a tough call okay that
was such a good answer because i wanted
to ask you
i was at a point in my life where
because i had kids and i was really
confused about what to do and where to
go next
this show and opportunity
hadn't presented itself to me right now
but i was
at a point where i really didn't know
what to do with my life or where to go
and is it true that you had an
intersection like that
before this is us presented itself
yeah i
truly yes i mean i've been doing this
since i was 15. so i'm 38 years old now
and um i'm not sure what would have
happened had it not because i definitely
just felt like i was at this juncture of
my life where
i was like maybe i should move back to
florida which is where i grew up and
just start over
um but luckily it didn't come to that
and just having patience and
perseverance and and you know extreme
luck for this this incredible project to
sort of
find me
well i have always respected you so much
and
um you actually have partnered with a
very special company who i'm a huge fan
of and we're teaming up with them today
on the show and i would love for you to
tell everybody about optilite by
luminous
yes so
you know for years i have suffered from
dry eye disease and i didn't even know
that i had it i wear contact lenses and
i couldn't wear my contact lenses for
very long and eye drops didn't really do
anything and it just was this constant
battle and frustration for me on set and
at home and it was something that i i
just assumed i would have to live with
and i'm really thrilled with optilite
it's it's this light based treatment for
dry eyes it's quick it's comfortable
there's no downtime and as an actor like
my eyes are obviously a gigantic part of
how i tell the story so i was really
really satisfied with the the fact that
there was no downtime required because
that was kind of a must for me and it
helped me the very first treatment that
i had i felt uh i felt relief and um
i've just been really really happy with
the results it's fantastic highly
recommend
okay thank you for bringing that
awareness and attention to everyone
um and
congratulations mama thank you for
joining us
thank you to luminous
and we'll be right back
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you